marina good to talk to you today you
were never in any doubt that russia were
behind what happened to your husband and
of course that was the finding of a
british inquiry why did you feel the
need to take it to the european court of
human rights
i i think it's a very important to all
of us to my legal team to my relatives
to our friends because from very
beginning when sasha was
killed
not uk received a lot of support from
european countries and this case was uh
just sorted by british police scotland
yard and we were waiting for another
five years to bring this to
justice but was it not justice it was in
quest and finally public inquiry even
after that in 2015 when we completed
public inquiry in 2016 when we received
result and it was first time saying
russia stayed behind of this crime it
was not a great support from other
countries unfortunately 2018
happened what we just heard about
skripal and now when we have this
decision from european
human rights courts it's a very
important to all of us to be accepted
more than just in uk in this case of
alexander litvinyanka it was just
started what we know now this is brutal
regime from russia committed not only
inside of russia and outside of russia
too
the court the european court has ordered
russia to pay you 122 000 euros i mean
do you imagine that russia ever will
again i don't know and from very
beginning it was the most important part
of my uh claim the most important what
we received now is a russia state
responsible for this crime because this
is message
not just for might circle this is a
great message for people inside of
russia
europe and other parts of the world is
not weak and not decide to give up to
fight against this anti-democratic
regime in russia and this case helps
another people not give up and try to
change what might happened in russia in
one day and russia became better country
to everybody
having said that of course the court
wasn't unanimous there was
one judge on the court uh
coincidentally a russian judge who found
many deficiencies in the analysis by the
british inquiry and the court do you
think there's any justification for
those comments
i i think again uh to bring this case to
human rights of
european human rights of course it was
not only about
what happened to us
since 2006 we can find and count a lot
of
criminality what happened from russia
state to in other countries uh taking
part of the war like in georgia in
ukraine uh killed individuals poisoned
individuals what we actually know for
for now but how many cases we don't know
and this is a still big question tag how
we can be with russia for now after all
of this
andrei lugevoir who's one of the men of
course that was accused of killing your
husband and says that that this court
case was politically motivated
how would you respond to that
i i don't like to go to discussion to
murder of my husband but you never heard
anything else it was always politically
motivated nothing else we provided a lot
of
scientifical evidence a lot of criminal
evidence but nothing from russia russia
always denies
do you think russia will ever
admit what it did or apologize to you
new russian yes this one not
what happens now is this the end of the
legal road for you
uh we still have uh this hope to bring
people who committed this crime for
justice to uk and when a regime will
change in russia i'm sure it will happen
and and what about you and your life now
how are you managing uh without
alexander lipfinenko and presumably you
must be concerned about your own safety
i can't say i i have lived this life
without my husband sasha i give him
voice
and he's been hurt everything what he
tried to provide when he was alive
unfortunately
people couldn't understand how is it
serious
but after his death more and more people
here in uk all around the world and even
in russia
understood what sasha tried to say
he tried to prevent this regime but he
was alone and he was not supported now
it's quite late regime became very
strong but what i believe
this regime
has end and one day it will be finished
but what about you are you worried about
your own physical safety
well for the last 15 years i wasn't i
really worried just in the beginning
when i was tested positively for
polonium and polonium 2010 was so
unusual um
i'd say a
moment in your body you never know how
your body will react but of course it
was not as strong what sasha received
and i didn't die immediately
and i pretty
fit for last 15 years it's i'm very
happy for this i had chance to see my
son
grow up now he's an adult
it's exactly what i wished and i would
say
i my life was good because i provided
what i believed i should provide for
sasha and now it's a very important day
for me
marine liberienko thanks so much for
joining us
thank you very much